jean luc mélenchon était en hologramme
attrape ce mardi 5 avril le meeting
s'est déroulé à la merise pour cette
dernière ligne droite avant le premier
tour des élections présidentielles un
multi meeting depuis lille en simultané
dans onze autres villes clés parmi
lesquels trappe la seule d'ile-de-france
la commune yvelinoise a été choisi selon
plusieurs critères
une ville populaire un maire engagé ou
encore le temps de trajet à notre maire
qui soutient jean luc mélenchon qui fait
partie en fait du parlement d'union
populaire et du coup ça a été aussi à
mon avis un critère de choix pour venir
ici dans ce dans cette ville hautement
symbolique dans les yvelines et en
france le critère c'était aussi que
chaque personne qui souhaitait se rendre
à son ultime de logram n'est pas à se
déplacer plus de deux heures autour de
chez elle donc l'idée c'était aussi de
quadriller le territoire
compte technique déjà utilisée en 2017
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle pour ce multi meeting le
nombre de villes en simultané à
augmenter et la technologie a été
améliorée
pourtant il ya quelques années qui sont
passés par exemple hologramme cad en
2017 et un peu moins coloré un peu moins
un peu moins réaliste et c'est
intéressant aussi pour montrer que la
politique bah ça se renouvelle au signal
porte à porte les collages le marché que
je très traditionnelle et qu'on est
qu'on fait depuis toujours et puis aussi
des choses nouvelles qui attire un
public plus jeune un public aussi
curieux de voir les hologrammes près
d'un millier de personnes étaient au
rendez-vous des militants qui viennent
de toute l'ile-de-france poursuivre le
programme et découvrir l'hologramme
penser une manière différente de faire
de la politique c'est bien que ça rentre
un peu dans le 21e siècle et qu'on en
fasse ça différemment c'est vraiment un
choix convaincu et surtout
une satisfaction pouvoir voir son
hologramme ce soir il sera avec nous
d'une certaine manière le plus important
c'est le fond c'est le programme c'est
ce programme est vraiment une réponse à
la crise aux crises multiples qu'on
traverse le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle aura lieu ce dimanche 10
avril